Hi, I'm Jason from the
Google Sign-in team.
I'm going to talk with you
about helping more Google users
sign into your app or website.
Connecting with your
users is important to you.
It's how you build a stronger,
more meaningful, and sometimes
more profitable
relationship with them.
But some users may not
be willing to jump right
into a deep, committed
relationship.
Asking for this
level of commitment
too early can turn
users off and make
them think of connecting to your
app as cheap and unimportant.
People naturally build trust
in a relationship over time.
That's why we're
excited to tell you
about incremental authorization.
With incremental auth,
you can let your users
connect with your app,
see what you're all about,
then decide to deepen
that relationship.
When you ask a user to authorize
your app to access data
during sign-in, she is
presented with a screen that
describes the data your
app is trying to access.
It's up to you as the developer
to put yourself in her shoes.
Ask yourself, will
she understand
why I'm asking for a
certain permission?
Are there so many
permissions that it
seems scary to sign into my app?
If she clicks through without
reading or understanding
exactly how a
permission works, how
will she feel later
if she finds out
she granted me this permission?
All of these answers
may affect the trust
that your current and future
users feel towards your app.
If your answers point to
showing fewer permissions,
you need something that will
simplify signing into your app.
To do this, you can
use incremental auth.
With incremental auth,
you can ask your user
to give just a basic
set of permissions
that are easy to accept,
like accessing her profile
information.
Profile information includes
her Google user ID, full name,
and profile image.
With just this basic connection,
you now have a way for her
to connect with your app
across different platforms
with just a single tap or click.
You can also personalize
her experience
by showing her profile image
and name inside your app.
Your app may also have great
collaboration or sharing
features.
After using it for
a while, your user
may find it useful to sign
into more Google services
within your app.
For example, if your app
allows him to create images,
he may want to upload them to
his Google Drive or share them
on Google+.
Incremental auth enables you to
ask him for these permissions
at exactly the right
time, when he has already
expressed interest by
interacting with a saving
or sharing feature in your app.
By providing the proper
context for the decision,
your user already
knows he's ready to use
more features of your app, to
be more involved in your app's
community, and to tell his
friends to come join him
in that community.
Letting your user understand why
you're asking for authorization
before asking for it can
dramatically increase
sign-in conversions, leading
to more users with a deeper
involvement in your app.
It's that simple.
You can use Google Sign-in
today to connect any Google
user to your app or website.
If you offer an option
to connect with Google+,
we make sure they have a Google+
account set up before your app
uses Google+ features.
But feel free to use any Google
API such as YouTube or Drive.
Consult the documentation
for the specific API
to decide which
permissions you need
to ask for before
calling the API.
And remember, it may be best
to ask for permissions one
at a time or to ask
for a few at a time.
The list just needs to
make sense to the user,
so they can feel
confident granting
your app the access it needs.
By using incremental auth
and building a relationship
with your user
over time, you can
build a long-term, harmonious
relationship with them.
I'm Jason from the
Google Sign-in team,
and you just learned
how incremental auth can
help you to grow your
signed-in Google users.
For more information
on how to get started
with incremental auth, check
out these pages on our developer
site and get ready
to grow with Google.
Thanks for watching.